Hey YouTubers it's Charlie! This is my Game
of Thrones Episode six video, totally cringe
worthy for a number of characters in really
horrifying amazing ways. New round of the giveaway
starts now, all you have to do to enter
is be a Subscriber and leave a comment on
this video. Careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet starting with
top seven moments, number seven Arya learns
to play the game of faces the last time we
saw her she was just learning to clean the
bodies now she's starting to wonder what happens
after the weight teaser with this really interesting
story about being the daughter of the Lord
who killed her stepmother and then fled to
join the faceless men is actually right out
of the books she really is the daughter of
an ancient noble house they never say which
one do you guys ought to wonder in the context
of the book she said to be about 36 years
old which is pretty close to how old Cersei
is supposed to be the reason she appears so
young is supposedly because she spent so much
time working with poison if it's affected
her the game of faces in itself is all about
lying learning to lie convincingly that's
why Jaqen was whipping her because he didn't
believe when Arya was telling her story she
was narrating everything that happened to
her since season one it just it didn't sound
real I guess to him I believed her but Jaqen's
a tough nut to crack it's not until she helps
the little girl lying convincingly saying
you know that the water heals her that the
show tells us she's learned the game of faces
that moment felt a little contrived and he
knows all about Jack and realizing that she
had learned to play the game of faces onto
number six Tyrion tells Jorah his father is
dead this is a pretty heartbreaking moment
I love that it actually opened up on him looking
at the grayscale that came right after Jaqen
said the game is never done I think the way
the edited that is just meant to imply that
the Jorah feels like he can only go forward
he knows is going to die so he says to keep
going Jorah knew that his father was at the
wall though when he was younger Jorah's father
abdicated his throne so that Jorah could understand
obviously since then things got on the ship
for Jorah he got caught slaving that's when
he entered the services of the crown as a
spy on Deanerys I do want to bet that his
father found out about that but just that
look of horror on Jorah's face when he finds
out that his father was murdered by his own
men it is the less you know that he still
cares about them a lot the show wants us to
sympathize with Ser Jorah even though I think
the books paint them in a less than pathetic
way the man's dying he just wants to serve
his call Lisi I love the way he and Tyrion
argue back and forth what's can happen when
she becomes Queen how do you know she's going
to be a good queen Targaryens are famously
insane all very good questions onto number
five Jaqen takes Arya into the hall of faces
as she's walking dead you notice this like
many other core doors branching off so there's
many other levels to the house of black and
white that we haven't seen yet the hall of
faces is just like the most spectacular looking
one seriously it's like 20/30 foot high ceilings
with just faces piled to the ceiling look
at how perfect those faces look to this is
perfectly preserved they went this far what
I'm hoping is is that we actually get to see
a faceless person apply a face like actually
get to see it happen they make it look like
magic when Jaqen does that but it's more of
a practical thing you're literally wearing
someone else's face and no Jackie made it
sound like you know you is your tong eyes
like everything about you technically it's
really just the face is not just a simple
as putting a hollowing mask on but the probably
spell that out in future episodes it is both
grotesque and amazing you guys lose your mind
of the great when he says she's not ready
to become a faceless person but she is ready
to become someone new this is just like her
getting ready to start her first mission what
to the faceless people do they kill people
for money so presumably were going get to
watch are you trying to kill someone onto
number four tearing it Jorah get captured
by Slavors we finally found out what Mr. Echo
is doing on the show he's playing one of the
slavers that take tearing it Jorah cut off
his caulk and sell it towards cocks are magical
people pay good money for that stuff such
a great callback to episode three when Tyrions
like you should rub my caulk I hear it's good
luck that is what you get for being a smart
ass on game of thrones somebody count the
number of times said cock and he just barely
manages to save himself and then tries to
tell them that Jorah is like one of the best
fighters ever so they won't sell them into
common slavery does in the fighting pit submarine
where they're trying to go just explain the
difference like if he hadn't of gotten them
to believe Jorah is is really great fighter
they would've been sold as common slaves and
who knows where they would ended up by going
to the fighting pits there that much closer
to Deanerys will be within looking distance
of Deanerys think and say hey you know it's
me Sir Jorah and remembered Deanerys said
no slaves allowed in the fighting. So technically
Jorah won't be a slave but now we find out
how he ends up in the scene we saw from the
the season five trailer and he actually is
a really good fighter I mean he's no Sir Barristan
Selmy buddies pretty close that comment he
made about Sir Jorah being your almost 60
being a little over the hill was a nice mirror
for Ariel talking to Jamie saying when you
are whole this would've been a good fight
like yeah both of these guys amazing fighters
but not quite in their prime anymore onto
number three Jaime and Bronn versus the Sand
Snakes makes this is so much fun and it's
a bit of a big departure from the book so
just explain that first in the books Irion
Martel convinces Aerys oh card that they will
put Myrcella on the throne and supplant Tommen
and Cersei Myrcella will be the new Queen
of the kingdom the sense makes it just part
of that they get caught on the way to Kings
Landing Myrcella gets her ear cut off by dark
star who is in the character on the show Aerys
oh card gets killed by area with his giant
acts in the sense makes get put under lock
and key foods like a failed version of what
the sense makes her trying to do now or is
it also got captured at the end of this in
the episode so it seems like but that's the
end of it the big changes are you know it
already stand change for Irion Martel Aerys
oh card change for Bron and Jamie and no one
died or got their ear chopped off we saw four
more episodes is still plenty going on this
drawing storyline but it was just one of the
best fight scenes we've had in a while Bron
amazing fighter you're pretty good to for
such a little girl and when he punched Tristan
out such a fancy little boy does not look
like a good fighter I also love how that moment
was preceded by area saying yes I definitely
remember how to use my ask when you are whole
it would've been a good fight don't worry
if this seems like an ax to use I do think
we'll get to see him use that sometime this
season is just like a loaded gun sitting on
the table it's got a go off at some point
onto number to the high Spero puts Maurice
and Marjorie on trial Cersei has applied to
get rid of the Tyrells queen of torrents isn't
having any of it and I love the look that
she gave Cersei at the end when they were
taken away there's no way she can sell her
but she was the mastermind behind getting
rid of Joffrey or at least with Littlefinger's
help Littlefinger also trying to play Cersei
against the north so I think Littlefinger
in the Queen of torrents will form something
of an alliance to get rid of Cersei to but
mostly it's the Queen of thorns that has motivation
to do it Littlefinger explain the long con
the Queen of thorns is trying to get her family
out of jail maybe it was just me but it looks
like all of her really enjoyed testifying
against Loras like BB something was promised
to him maybe Cersei offered him gold whenever
they carried him away he seemed pretty terrified
and even if he made a bargain with the fate
he was still accused of being gay with Loras
so the church would try him just like they
would try Laura slipe given the same punishment
so Loras was sentenced to death so it all
over so I don't see why he's so excited but
now we get to see this awesome twisted version
of the trial that Tyrion got last season whenever
we do get to the trial just look for similarities
between that that Tyrion trial scenes and
you know whoever gets put on trial in the
season remember with the high Spero said to
Kings and Queens are not above justice so
it doesn't matter who you are once you land
on the radar she goes down and finally under
my number one WTF moment Sansa gets married
to Ramsey say yes to the Winterfell dress
fences dress that she was fairly beautiful
even though that this whole scene just completely
horrifying both beautiful and terrible and
notice how it started this note just as the
ceremony started winter is calm how ominous
and appropriate I just love how the only smile
in the house right in this moment is Ramsey
everyone else either doesn't care hates it
or is terrified in the betting scene just
took things to a whole new level no-no Reek
you stay here you watch Ramsey had this creepy
calm but that you know then he started to
slip in the classic Ramsey crazy you're not
lying are you that be a bad way to start the
marriage I think they did a good job you know
that Lassie painting in on Reek's face as
he was watching what was happening to Sansa
is so much more horrifying because you just
you left a magic like your mind fills in the
gaps of what's happening with Sansa it seems
pretty clear that there setting up Reek for
some sort of redemptive moment like you can
say enough is enough I can expected them to
do it in this scene so here's my big question
for you guys how long you think it's going
to be before Reek tries to save Sansa do you
think is going to try and save Sansa I just
felt like that was with that whole last scene
was about like really just being completely
horrified and if you think about it he remembers
his name he remembered all the words of that
wedding ceremony so he very clearly has some
of his mind left like he hasn't completely
turned to mush the books are little more hazy
on his his level of sanity but sometimes he
has trouble remembering things that he's so
fully become this week character the show
seems a good tune that down just a little
bit like he's a little closer to the Albany
is to Reek so I'm just waiting for a Reek
bomb to explode all over Ramsey's face there
was so much talk of dwarf cock I was actually
kind of hoping that Reek would try to cut
Ramsey's off. That would be a nice twist on
what Ramsey did to Reek. I feel like that
would be a nice way to close Ramsay's arc.
He is such an interesting character that the
show might not kill him off for a while that's
really the problem with characters like Ramsey
you know that are good the more interesting
you are better chance you have for staying
on the show let's circle back around to Littlefinger
real quick to because he issues is something
really important for this northern storyline
make me Warden of the North if I can get rid
of the Boltons technically Sansa would be
Wardeness of the North now but don't think
Littlefinger is trying to sell Sansa out I
still think that he cares for her in in a
really weird way what he was trying to do
is just play Kings Landing against the Boltons
because supposedly this post to be helping
the Boltons but if he convinces Cersei that
there doublecrossing them then he can break
that alliance is just trying to cut the Boltons
off of all their support way for Stannis margin
see how goes down and then take down the winter
don't forget to Brienne is staying in winter
town right near Winterfell so hopefully we'll
get to see how she's going to try and help
Sansa overall just a terrifyingly amazing
episode don't forget though Q&A is going to
post tomorrow i'll announce the winner of
my Q&A all you have to do to enter is be a
Subscriber and leave a comment on this video
while you wait for that to post you can click
here to learn all about the Targaryen Restoration
that do doing on the show and some changes
from the books and you can click here for
last week's Episode. Thank You so much watching,
everybody with High Five, see you guys tomorrow!